[Applause]
welcome back everybody it's just over a
year since the tragic passing of Steven
twitch boss this month his wife Allison
will release a children's book that they
wrote together before his passing it's
called keep dancing through a Boss
family Groove and it celebrates a day in
the life of their beautiful family
please welcome Alison Hulker
[Applause]
[Music]
boss
[Applause]
[Music]
man you and Jamie are really into like
the Fall colors that us almost like
y'all both look like Earth elements
today I wanted to make sure I fit the
part being here with you y always look
so beautiful oh I do nothing I sit in a
chair girl um you almost didn't release
this book I imagine because it's so
personal yeah so back in 2021 with my
late husband we wrote this book and it
really was just a testament to our
family we wanted to write something that
shared a day in the life of who we are
what we are and we really believe in
affirmation so you really follow my kids
each going this journey and how we get
through everything yeah so then when
everything happened I didn't know if I
wanted to release the book because part
of me selfishly wanted to hold on to it
for myself and for my kids just to have
something like a time capsule for us to
look back on yeah so I almost selfishly
held on to it for myself and then my gut
reaction I just started reading it over
and over and over again I was reading
the title keep dancing through and I was
like that's all I can do and that's all
I can do with my kids and what I can
teach them and I felt like God in
Universe was like no you have to do this
because everyone that's followed my
journey and followed his journey and our
family coming together and me having
kids with him everyone's been so
supportive and love lovely and it was a
way for me to give back to them that
they can keep dancing through as well
absolutely and what a message for your
family too when tragedy you know fell
upon your family you know what I'm
saying what a message and I think that's
the thing is you're a living breathing
version of that you got to keep dancing
through it and and speaking of that
actually I I want to cut to this real
quick because I love this so this is the
first time that you danced since your
husband's passing and I want to show
everybody
this H um love this yeah it was um it
took me doesn't it feel good I love
dancing so much I'm not you but I love I
don't look like that dancing but I love
dancing I don't care it feels so good to
express yourself in that way and to like
not be able to do that because I imagine
like how precious that is like even more
so now like that you fell in love with a
dancer you know you both are so
expressive your family I imagine all of
you were like that it just feels good
right to release dancing for me has been
always my safe
it's where I've gone to be able to
express myself and story tell and and
honestly just feel like the most me that
I can feel yeah and after you know
losing something and having this
connection with something that was with
someone that was so big I did not know
if I was ever going to dance again cuz
it was something that we treasured
together individually and it was a way
for us to express ourselves and I think
I was really scared of dancing again
because it would make it real and then
about 6 months later I was like you know
what it's time I've got to do this for
me I've got to do it for him I've got to
give him the peace and the grace and
show your kids and show my kids that
like we can do this and we can do the
hard things which is something I always
say with my kids is we can do the hard
things so I did the hard thing I but I
wanted to do it with someone I didn't
want to do it alone so I brought my
friend over and we danced together and
oh I felt so free yeah freedom and it
was it was a release and energy and it
was so healing for myself and so I I was
kind of mad that it took me a second to
do it but also proud myself for getting
back out there and doing and doing it
and um my my kids were excited about it
and they were literally watching me
while I was dancing and I was proud of
myself I really was and it's something
that and then watching you smile then
watching you be like that's that's a
sometimes actions speak louder than
words I know everybody says all the time
but it is true it is and I think
sometimes what I'm learning with grief
is I've always known that it was going
to be a mental
and spiritual um test that you have to
get through I didn't understand that it
was going to be so physical and I felt
it actually take over my body sometimes
when my my body actually ate at times
and so being able to have dance to
release that energy off of me was such a
a fantastic moment for me to find it
again and fall in love with it in a new
way and have a completely different
understanding of what it is to me
appreciation and the appreciation and
again being able to share it with people
that have been there for me I wanted
them to know that like this is really
hard but I'm going to do it with you
guys I'm going to bring you guys a part
of this journey and um it's been
something that we have not stopped doing
cuz now we dance in our house all the
time like we always did yes I really
want my kids to know and accept that
it's okay to have fun yeah that has been
something that I doesn't mean everything
ends like you know that when grief hit
sometimes it feels like that it feels
like well how do you go how do you start
again like how do you yeah every season
has an expiration date that means that
the hard times they are going to end and
you're going to get to the other side
and you're going to be okay sun will
come up the sun will come back out and
you're going to be fine and you're going
to be able to laugh again and you're
going to be able to smile but also on
that same note the good times also have
an expiration date so you must find
gratitude and the joy of life because
life is the gift MH so every season has
an expiration date yeah yeah that's a
book we should WR um well if you are
someone you know is looking for Mental
Health Resources please check out the
National Alliance on Mental Illness uh
we have to take another short break but
keep dancing through a Boss family
Groove is available right now and
everyone here is going home with a
[Applause]
[Music]
copy
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home